بقطع امريكيه ويابانيه تصنع ايران
مسيراتها المرسله الى روسيا والتي
تستخدمها الاخيره لضرب البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه معلومات كشفت استخبارات كياف
لصحيفه وصف الجرن الامريكيه ووفقه معلومات
استخباراتيه اكدت ان ثلاثه ارباع مكونات
وسيارات الايرانيه المستخدمه ضد اوكرانيا
امريكيه في اشاره الى مسيرات مهاجر سته
وشاهد 136 التي تم تصنيعها باجزاء ومعدات
غربيه المعلومات الاستخباراتيه كشفت عن
اكبر سلسله توريد غربي للمسيرات الايرانيه
التي تشمل المحركات ولوحات التحكم وانظمه
المراقبه فلقد اوضح الجيش الاوكراني ان
اكثر من 200 مكون داخلي لمو سيارات مهاجر
16 وشاهد 136 تم تصنيعها نصفها بواسطه
شركات مقرها في الولايات المتحده وحوالي
ثلث بواسطه شركه في اليابان فعلى سبيل
المثال مسيرات شهد 136 والتي اطلق عليها
اسم طائرات كاميكازي فتح تم تصنيعه من
المكونات الالكترونيه الخاصه بها من قبل
وحدات انفينيون تكنولوجيا المملوكه
المانيا وشركه اي جي مايكروسوفت تكنولوجيا
اي ان سي ومقرها اليسونا وبخصوص مسيرات
مهاجر سته فلقد تم تصنيع القطع التي تدعم
المحركات الخاصه بها من قبل شركه يابانيه
والتي تسمح للمشغلين بمناوره للمركبه غير
الماهوله عبر الهواء في حين يرى خبراء
عسكريون بان حدثت الاشعه تحت الحمراء
التلسكوبيه عاليه الدقه المستخدمه في
مهاجر سته للمراقبه والاستهداف مطابقه
للنموذج صنعته شركه اسرائيليه
كما ان معهد العلوم والامن الدولي هو
واشنطن قال ان الشركات الصينيه زودت ايران
بنسخ من السلع الغربيه لانتاج الطائرات
القتاليه بدون طيار
[موسيقى]